[Music]
in too persistent news submitted by
British army brat
that sounds thirsty I'll call an
American man was killed after attempting
an illegal missionary trip on a
protected remote island give us a taste
he went to the Sentinel Islands yeah oh
I heard about this where is that it is a
Aylin is that the only one that has a
course of India and this tribe has been
like non contacted for hundreds of years
the Sentinelese no it's a hundred it's a
couple hundreds yeah it's been sick they
haven't changed their life style for
sixty thousand years yes sixty thousand
people show up they just straight kill
your ass yeah so they are an estimated
100 tribes people living in North India
of this island and so they have been
throughout the years they have been
contacted by the outside world but then
every time someone tries to contact them
they always end up killing everybody
because there was this one really bad
incident in 1880 where British colonial
expedition went in and then the
Explorers kidnapped two elderly tribes
people and four children and then the
adults quickly became sick and they died
and then the children were immediately
returned to the island with gifts and
and they said that he was he was
molesting the kids and do a weird [ __ ]
and taking pictures of them and he was
like taking pictures of Dixons [ __ ] yeah
I remember this measuring their dicks
with the [ __ ] tape over the head
cameras yeah he was sexualizing them and
then it was written in his journal and
stuff it was like very erotic yeah so
this weird [ __ ] guy went into the
island and that's their only experience
of this like foreign contact right so
then all this stuff happened now they
just think like they're they're like
evil or like visible
this [ __ ] crazy yeah because like a
lot of people died because of the they
don't have immunity to the disease a lot
of weird perverted [ __ ] happen and he
just [ __ ] it all up
for everybody else so now if anyone
washes up too short they want to kill
them yeah and they have they've been
killing fishermen that washed up to
shore and then there was this one
incident where they like the government
was trying to retrieve these two
fishermen that died there but because
they're so hostile that they actually
tried like a helicopter thing and they
started like shooting arrows at the
helicopter and they just oh that's what
they're known for
and after the there was just a recently
in earthquake tsunami over there and
they flew choppers over there to see if
they were okay and then they got a bunch
of arrows so they're like okay I guess
they're okay
like the arrows really matter there's
like the message yeah okay thank you
yeah you're still there yeah so this
American dude he is 27 year old named
John he went to the island he was trying
to convert the island [ __ ]
self-righteous idiots man well he was
also he wrote in his journal like like I
I know I could die but I really believe
in what I'm doing kind of [ __ ] blinded
me why doesn't he just I mean I guess
that's just religion right dude I'm like
go confer people at the gas station bro
what are you doing here yeah they're
fine suddenly there's only like probably
50 of them maybe 30 like because they've
been so well I've read that those
numbers are way to pleat it from there
yeah but it used to be thousands and
then a lot of them died and then there's
a neighboring island I think they're
called a Jawa knees or something like
that
and they are actually have contact and
within that a short period of time
their population dwindled to like really
small numbers and they're on the verge
of extinction they probably got
McDonald's there now though that's yeah
with like custom McDonald's items with
one pissed off employee yeah he was like
I'm the only guy here to do all of it so
this is John three seven year old okay
he has that kind of smile on his face
like I'm gonna change the looks like
Asian his last name is Tao Oh Charlies
ch8 you that's that's a Chinese last
name Chao oh yeah yeah so then what
happened here is a fisherman took him to
the island he got off the boat he went
to shore he he said my name is John I
love you and Jesus loves oh my thing to
understand that yeah shooting arrows oh
my god it pierced the Bible there's the
Bible
yeah he swam back and he wrote in his
journal and like he wrote a letter to
his family and he was just saying like I
don't want to die there's so much this
Evan so beautiful there's so much death
and then what else did he write she said
he's like yeah but I have to see what is
possible no I read that he I read that
he wrote all that before he went to the
island and then he got to the island
just basically got executed like
immediately
no there was two contacts there's two
because she did that on the 16th of
November and then the next day he went
back oh I seen them yeah that's when
they go yeah I just saw him he tried
again he tried again there is footage of
a bunch of scientists that went try to
make contact and they were doing it in a
way different way like they were just
giving them coconuts and gifts and then
you can kind of see like they want the
coconuts but they don't trust these guys
and they were like making you know they
were in a safe distance and then
something happened to where the in the
the tribe was like nah [ __ ] that they
gotta go and then they were like getting
aggressive and so they were like whole
[ __ ] and the scientists left yeah
that was like with another indigenous
tribe no that was the the center yeah
there's V there's footage on YouTube and
they're like giving coconuts to the guys
and stuff and then like they were taking
them but then at the same time you could
kind of feel like the tension and then
they turn on them and not really
white people that are trying to go over
there cuz maybe that's not helping the
situation this guy's that Chinese guy go
right compared to like an indigenous
like you know there are Indians what
about if the woman loves you does it
matter
that's pretty good but also we could
just leave them alone I feel like why do
is yeah big teach you leaders but make
it we haven't tried it yet yeah right
why does anyone need to go there anyway
like if they're self-sufficient like
leave them do it so much as people and
stuff I just be like why do you think
cuz it's like you think your way of
living is better than their like they
could be completely happy and content
but you're like oh no they need to be
saved respectfully that built this
country we're here cuz they raped and
pillaged our people oh yeah we created
us right and they're like oh why can't
you be more civilized like we are and
then like once they convert everybody
like see you're so civilize now I think
it's a it's mainly for the scientists
want to study because there's a direct
link to how humans naturally were to the
people that were not contacted and how
they're living from like there's it's
almost like you can see the stone Age's
happen in real life
that's high well and recently they got
metal because apparently some boat
washed ashore and they had to abandon
the boat and rescue everybody on board
with choppers and they're getting air
the whole time but they got metal from
this boat so now the Sentinelese have
like metal tools and [ __ ] yeah they
learned how to forge metal like they
took pieces of that and then they're
like sharpening it and making all kinds
of stuff now bangin bangin with the
rocket enough times you can yeah it's
cold for jay-z I wish I could just drop
some cameras down there and just see
some [ __ ] YouTube just so I could
observe I always think about like okay
it's like we're really advanced what if
you had like a [ __ ] some way to
protect yours your body like you build
like an almost like an Iron Man suit and
you go there and you just show them [ __ ]
on your phone and stuff I've heard while
you're go you're gonna [ __ ] them up well
I don't want to [ __ ] them up I just like
our military has some sort of bodysuit
that I would not get pierced by their
boys
the bombs yeah
flack the flack things yeah not for sure
I'm like dude we probably came up with
the arrow proof like a thousand years
ago but we just wouldn't waste our time
on a drone you know like no but like a
bird drone or like something that look
normal
drone is genius they try to eat it it's
like hang on scientists make sure to
keep them weaving that looks like a real
snake
[ __ ] idiots figured out how to do a
snake drum make animal drones I love it
and then what within one then one just
to observe yeah just observe I think
because they don't have immunity to our
like our common core could kill them
so I wouldn't want us to that like you
know yeah but I want it but I want to
show them Star Wars [ __ ] with their
heads do you guys want to see do you
ever watch did you watch this at school
like how there was this uncontacted like
try back in a day and there's footage
it's like produced in the 70s but then
they introduced like glass bottles and
things to there try seeing something
like they're like they see like an
airplane and then once they seen it they
try to rebuild it with like wood and
stuff and then they would have a
ceremony every year to honor that God
Wow
cuz the plane flew over yeah yeah shows
how dumb we all are yeah and they got
over like they got into a big fight over
a glass bottle that they all wanted to
have and they all and then they started
worshipping the glass bottle because it
was a god there's like a whole shrine it
was at the very top yeah yeah that's
like how we all are even now yes and
love all our customs and [ __ ] like why
why we put a Christmas tree up and
decorate with ornaments and all [ __ ] we
do your Christmas trees really nice
thank you no but I just you know when
you step back and you think about it
versus Tom weird like so a bunch of apes
you know Christmas is an American
invention like the way we celebrate in
every hand oh yeah I just watched a
documentary of how it all came together
this was like real and like from a long
time ago yes and we just dropped
I just dropped like five bills on
Christmas decorations I know it's an
American tradition yeah but how much
money we spend on [ __ ] exactly it's
like well I gotta go get
we're crazy but if you go to Europe they
do Christmas the [ __ ] right way
what's the right way well first of all
they have like snow right but then they
have Christmas markets and then the
whole bicester that's a muddle town
comes out and there's like a bunch of
booths with food different Christmas
booth yeah yeah like the the center of
the of the town and they just go ham
with Christmas that's like no you can't
they have that before the Christmas as
we know it as like a family thing it
used to be a [ __ ] up Mardi Gras kind
of thing where people were parading down
the street Jewish titties getting [ __ ]
up titties in the winter like titties
for beads no like orgies and [ __ ]
Christmas like the 1600s or some [ __ ]
like old Oh everyone was doing that and
no like they didn't have a family kind
of Christmas that's a very new boy I
think you just saw National Lampoon
movie no it's a documentary they would
they even had like some kind of what do
you call it like some controversy at
like a Royal Court where they would just
binge drink three four days and then
this guy got in trouble for [ __ ] like
a teenage girl getting her pregnant and
then like he went to jail and all that
stuff just sounds like an American
holiday I don't know maybe it wasn't
normal for that cuz think about it
and third during Thanksgiving time and
the whole family's in town he basically
binge drink every night and then your
uncle does some stupid [ __ ] yeah and it
becomes like the story I you retell over
and over the whole year pretty similar
there's nothing to do in a winter anyway
especially out in Europe I mean like
they're just snowed in they just drink
all day and party sounds nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]